[Music]
always love your style every time I see
you and I'm not even a style person so
this is reaching an audience is what I'm
saying I appreciate that immensely you
know
I had to pack yesterday to come here are
you good Packer or you pack way too much
it depends okay there's moments where
I'm like I am tapped in to packing right
now I have 12 outfits for the next three
days yeah it's really the next three
days yesterday I was like I need 17
pairs of underwear two pairs of socks I
was just out of it I am so different
from you I'm like I have three pairs of
like legging type workout things that I
will not be working out in but I'm gonna
wear them every day and t-shirts and a
jacket and like two shoes in case one
breaks like I'm like I'm the worst I
think it's touring so much though yeah I
didn't want to Lug all the everywhere
you're not supposed to say I
I know I'm keeping it daytime
[Music]
[Applause]